808 news now in conical event all over
town gifting good days helping folks pay
for their gas heather mills surprised a
conoco customer take a look
at the conoco on centennial parkway i
met emily a local teacher on her lunch
break you know gas prices actually las
vegas does have one of the highest gas
prices in the country have you have you
seen the numbers going up what do you
think yeah i've definitely noticed i'm
going up i mean i drive like 40 miles
today so it's not
i live by the strip and i teach in north
vegas emily and her husband are saving
to buy a house so she tries to save
where she can we don't really spend a
lot of money like outside
then it was time for the surprise
channel 8 news and conoco would like to
gift you a good day
and we would like to buy your gas today
you are so welcome this will get you one
step closer to your house yes
after completely filling up her tank
emily had cash left she bought her
students some snacks inside the conoco
market and even had enough left for a
vip car wash
it has been a great month given away
free gas at conoco can't wait to
continue gifting you a good day i think
we've all had the pleasure of making
somebody's day and there's nothing
better it really feels good especially
when you can tell it makes a huge
difference in their money uh matters
yeah
and it does i think for all of us right
now because it hurts
to fill up at the pub yeah i went
yesterday and
it's almost like the stock market you're
trying to buy low expecting it to go
higher and it doesn't matter it's still
expensive it's it's you know four or
five bucks a gallon it's crazy yeah